hello and welcome to this video why it's
a funny one it's video 4444 I just saw
that right before the recording so I
hope I'm doing well yeah but the funny
number funny anniversary number
I am never end Xavier Mourinho Louise
okay so it goes age six this is a little
bit better for why just this line age
six is not considered to be a critical
but okay
it is a playable move of course so I
think this is right h6v concerned a
little bit and this is why it is not
considered them to be all that great but
I will see um I can go an ITN generate
with surprising that he goes there in
the first place okay II five and then
Bishop c5 I was expecting more
understand I can take and nights you
form now no he does not have a really
bad bishop yet it can become weak but it
is not yet so I don't think this is all
that fantastic now it's not going to
play c5 is he I have some ideas here 93
I don't know that I can answer at night
to 4 there should be force interesting
try to I mean this discuss is first
I mean b5 it's not a movie wants to play
I guess facing a 6 ok so here probably
grabbing now right still so very equal I
think I had something I remember similar
ending in a recent game with in blitz
game I mean not in tournament chess when
when I won at the end but that was not
really and something forced
I don't really have enough control in
this position to do much
I might just play c5 okay let's see five
is a concession so while putting another
pawn on a dark square okay so I think
that is somewhat one-sided ending now
maybe I'm just not understanding this
ending it's got c4 what is the thing we
cannot play c4 I play 93 95
[Music]
start with this and be 5v5 I can maybe
play c4 it's an interesting move see
form Bishop takes I can take and go to
see that's an interesting move
I've got chunky form actually I mean I
don't know how bad it is I have 90
forward it was not hit something I said
I considered correctly
never should be for that one let's see
what it does
yeah I mean I have to do it then there's
nothing else okay so if I take getting
skis going back so I have to grab this
the edge point is strong isn't it just
promoting why isn't it just promoting
actually I take f7 and I just put it and
put it home we making is easily
controlling the queenside let strange
I didn't see that before I added that
that night reform I was a bit lucky
already like c4 and this seems to work
no one would be funny if I started this
game black version almost I got to add
2444 almost so um yeah let's let's have
a look a I'm really just promoting I was
surprised that he played c5 I mean this
is probably okay but interesting here 94
mm well I'm getting aged six there no it
would be interesting would have been
interesting Germany's got things going
for himself them with check that's a
very strange ending
and okay then
I'm interested in this okay so I played
it in a very simple way he fixes make
sense I went here and now we went b5 and
now I played this move which is
interesting and one point is that if he
takes here I grab and I get here
King be 694 is a fork and this is a very
unpleasant ending because I control all
of this and my beep one is strong I
think very good chances to to win here
so that cannot be all that great if he
takes Knight takes Bishop f4 the engine
claims this is equal
this is not a position where a human
player would be very comfortable maybe
with black yeas h6 is such a such an
obvious weakness but maybe I didn't get
there simply
no I don't get that probably the what
the what he should do this this and
Bishop g7 is still okay yeah yeah this
is here and there the line that the
engine is giving here this is line looks
pretty dreadful yeah
but maybe I don't I don't really have
anything it looks pretty bad because
everything is on dark squares but this
this this and maybe I'm not getting
anywhere the engine giving zero zero
zero points towards that actually my
knife does not have a square I can do
this and now we have to take everything
else loses
and I probably cannot out remove them
here you know looks nice but it's
probably a draw
okay guys thanks for watching oh I
forget to switch on analysis again
anyway thanks for watching